reject so I'm going to start off I think
thank you all for that beautiful
introduction I'm kind of embarrassed
actually um I also want to take this
chance to say thanks to the whole reject
Jas family the organizers sponsors the
venue my wonderful Co speakers of course
and for all of you for coming out today
um this is a really awesome conference
so and this can happen without everybody
being here um so as allah mentioned my
name is jenn giacconi Cruz you might
know me as an AMA set of tricks from
Twitter i'm also with living style gorg
which is an open source project for
creating living style guides um as a
ruby gem and a little bit more on that
later um i am a product infrastructure
designer linguist and japan ologist um
and so some people aren't always
entirely sure what it is that I do but a
lot of what I do is going to be
explained or evidenced in my talk today
um oh there you um the title of my talk
is perfectly portable Japanese mobile
culture influencing the front end some
people might wonder how I arrived at
such a topic um well this is an
extension of a talk that I gave last
March at up front and in that talk I
discussed Japanese web and front end and
the factors that influence it and what
makes it so Japanese one of the sections
of my talk touched on Japanese mobile
phones also called Kate thide n1 and how
their growth into staple of Japanese
life in the 90s and Beyond shape the way
that Japanese web sites and the front
end work incepted structured and
ultimately how they've changed or
haven't changed in response to the way
that people use them
so today's going to be focusing a little
bit more on mobile phones and this talk
is going to focus on the role of the
mobile phone in Japan both past present
and future Japan's influence on mobile
design and development the current
mobile at culture and web in Japan and
the future of Japanese mobile culture as
evidenced from the past and also the new
smartphone culture that's cropped up in
the last seven years or so so what I'd
like to do autumn is to start off by
getting an idea of what you all know
about Japan um can I have a show of
hands has anyone here actually been to
Japan before okay and so of those of you
who haven't what's your impression of
mobile phones in Japan and how they're
used to any volunteers maybe shouts okay
anyone else okay so we have some ideas
about what it is um but actually it's
not always the way that it seems to be
um so here we've got a selection of Kate
I denwa Japanese flip phones I chose the
flip phone because I'm a little bit
nostalgic for the late 90s and early
2000s when I first went to Japan um and
actually this was one of the first times
that I had a mobile phone i went to
japan in 2002 after completing my grad
work and up until that point I hadn't
really had a mobile phone before I had
only had one for the last six months I
was studying in the US and at that time
we had those awful Nokia's that had the
replaceable face plates and they
couldn't really do very much except play
one game and they were really difficult
to SMS and there really wasn't much of a
mobile phone culture in the u.s. at that
time but when I arrived in Japan I saw
mobile phones like this and I saw people
actually doing things with them they
were looking at the web they were
writing each other a really long email
some people were reading novels on their
web
so to me that was completely shocking
and immediately I was hooked because
this vibrant culture that existed in
Japan was unlike anything I'd ever seen
before um so to give you an idea of the
role of the mobile phone in Japanese
culture and let's start with some
numbers um japan has a ninety-five
percent mobile subscription rate that's
about 130 4.8 million subscribers now
that's a lot I mean most countries don't
have that kind of subscription rate at
all of these 79.7 percent of the
subscribers are mobile Internet users so
roughly one hundred and seven point five
million that racks up to more than twice
the US average for web access on mobiles
this means that Japan is one of the
breeding grounds for not only web
technology but also for mobile web and
this is going to become more and more
evident as the talk it's all right um so
how did japan get there how did they get
such a high market penetration how did
they get people so actively using their
mobile phones to access the web well
it's all starts with a little bit of
catch up on history on mobile web so
let's go back to the 90's and although
the first actually commercially offered
mobile web was merged in finland in 1996
on the nokia 9000 in the 90 110 series
in 1997 which i'm particularly fond of
because it was featured in that awful
movie with alkyl over the st. if you
would remember that at all this was
offered by sonara andrade alenia
networks and there was kind of
accessible to the sense that like it
actually existed and people could use it
but it wasn't something that was part of
everyday life until the mobile web boom
in Japan and that happened around 1999
and this happened when NTT DoCoMo which
is one of the big three providers of
mobile service in Japan introduced the
first commercially offered browser
specific
mobile web service called I mode this
was a revolution because nobody really
had such a broad access to the internet
from their mobile phone before it was
very much about direct connections to
the network but here they were able to
package it within a commercial framework
it was based on C HTML which was around
for a hot minute back then HTML which
was around for a little bit longer and
WD ml which was around a little bit
later and a little bit longer as well
and also proprietary alp and TLP
protocols which was a huge jump forward
because they were able to provide
customized content um this happened by
actually literally pressing an eye mode
button so the button had this little
logo there and it was a button on the
phone itself and you pressed it and you
got connected to the web and there was a
little animation that showed like some
kind of connection happening as if a
virtual coupling had happened and that
was a pretty exciting moment because you
were wherever you were on the train you
were at school you were walking down the
street sitting in the park and you could
actually get some information um the
content was controlled by the provider
via the I mode websites so actually in
this case since I mode was provided by
ntt docomo NTT DoCoMo was responsible
for developing the website that the web
phone could access and this allowed for
better provider control over pricing &
billing because it was applied to both
send and receive data packets and here
you see that there's a lot of type
control over the exchange of data the
volume of data control and they had a
really tight lid on their networks which
is sort of an ongoing theme in Japanese
mobile providers and it didn't really
loosen up until rather recently and I'll
get to that in a little bit so you had a
phone like this you here's the I mode
screen you would hit the I mode button
which was often one of the buttons that
had an alternate use or sometimes there
was a little extra button down here
depending on the model
you had what's interesting about this
phone is it's a gadda k which is a also
a domestic phone so it's a phone that's
produced for domestic use in Japan and
I'll explain a little bit more about
them a little bit later as well so they
could have all of these extra
proprietary buttons that were specific
to the carrier's that sold them so you
would press the I mode button you'd get
connected you'd get to your I mode
screen and then what would happen is is
that you would actually encounter a
screen that looked like this and this is
where you would jump off in later years
a lot of these screens were actually
partnered up with providers like Yahoo
which is one reason why Yahoo is still a
massive massive influence in Japanese
web there was often directly a yahoo
menu that came down on the Left we have
I mode which was ntt docomo um and you
can see that there's lots of linking
happening you would use the numbers to
navigate down through on the right we
have easy web which is the similar
system analog for a UK DDI which is
another one of the big three providers
the third provider was j phone which
then became vodafone which is now
softbank and they had something called j
sky i happen to have a j phone when i
first arrived there it was the most
futuristic looking thing I'd ever seen
with silver it looked like a tiny
spaceship it flipped open it made
awesome noises I could play at least
five games whoo and um yeah and it was
it was a huge revelation for me and for
a long time this was my only way to
access the internet and you know what it
wasn't just me it was pretty much
everybody um so um a lot of providers
still followed suit so we had the easy
web a UK DD IJ sky IJ phone this put
japan in scandinavia at the forefront of
mobile web usage and this was long
before any web ready handsets had become
proliferated in the US and europe
as I mentioned before and this opened up
a whole new system ax tised way for
navigating the web on the go so as I
said this was mostly the main way for
people to access the web this was before
home internet connections were really
the norm in Japan most people from the
90s on until a lot of points in the
mid-2000s so around 2005 a lot of people
i knew still didn't have home internet
connections and they would have most of
their internet access either at work or
at school and if they weren't there it
was through their internet phone so that
was one of the reasons why japanese
mobile web became such a huge influence
this means that the market traction for
accessing web via mobile also became the
evolution of japanese web front-end and
this was partially them what was
actually mostly the point of the first
talk so really Japan was mobile first
before lots of other places so how did
we arrive at such an early mobile first
approach well this is through people
practices and power um wow man and hey
thornthwaite in there really fantastic
research piece the Internet of everyday
life said it really elegantly when they
said the internet is not a system of
floating se really above societies it is
embedded in the concrete realities of
people practices and power and I think
that we can all agree that this can be
applied to a lot of what happens on the
web and in this case I'm applying it to
mobile web access so let's take a look
at the people that are creating this
pillar of power and practices let's take
a look at the people using mobile there
aren't a whole lot of statistics that
are really available for the late 90s a
lot of the white papers which were
brought out by the ministry of
telecommunications aren't really that
informative about actual statistics
about web usage but more about the
concepts of its proliferation so the
first real hard look from a white paper
from the ministry of telecommunications
the japan is from about two thousand
and back then the average Emma graphic
was aged 20 to 29 and it broke down to
about 44 744 0.7% man man male the and
48.1 % female um fast forward a little
bit to 2011 and it's skewed slightly
higher um but then again we have to take
a look at some caveats there I'm sure in
Japan mobile web has always been the
realm of the youth remember that
benchmark year for the mobile web is
1997 so these are early adopters have
grown a little bit older um it's also
skewed younger in some ways if we
approach 2015 this is partially because
of smartphones but also it's because of
price normalization on mobile plans
mainstreaming of increasingly younger
kids having phones to communicate with
their parents and the general increasing
acceptance of mobile phones as a
necessity of our everyday lives but
that's said it's also skewed older um as
we all know Japan has a decreasing
population and a very highly aging
population and a lot of these
domestically produced phones are
marketed to the elderly with special
features that make them more useful to
them so they're more likely to actually
be able to use the mobile web or to be
interested in trying it because of these
phones so in some ways it's also
schooled Oh toad older one of the most
surprising statistics though is that the
fastest growing subset of mobile web
users is aged five years or younger
that's a little bit shocking um this
could possibly be because of smartphones
it could also be because parents are
seeing the Moors a utilitarian tool and
will also come back to this point a
little bit later so it's precisely these
ways of using the mobile web which bring
us to the next apex in this mobile
internet trifecta practices before the
advent of smartphones people were either
using low-end PHS phones or feature
phones these got a key so the gada k
were domestically produced smartphone of
basically produced feature phones
they're called got a cave because gotta
is short for a Galapagos and if we think
about Darwin's theory of evolution the
animals of the Galapagos Island had
special features that allowed them to
survive in their environment and much
like these animals in the Galapagos
Islands these Galapagos phones ghada k
have special features that are extremely
useful to consumers in the japanese
market and even today with the huge
cliff eration of smartphones throughout
the world even in japan there's a huge
passion for god okay in these feature
phones they still exist they're still
sold maybe the proportion of purchases
compared to the overall amount of mobile
phone purchases is a little bit smaller
but people still have a really nostalgic
passion for it which is something that I
find really interesting and they're
still accessible they still maintain the
networks that people use with those
phones to access the web so who knows
then a pinch they might come in really
handy still so again let's remember
we're talking about the mid to late 90s
when mobile web is really starting to
take hold we might still claim to the
image that Japan was the future manifest
and that in mobile web sense it was but
not in the way that we might have
imagined most people didn't have
internet connections at home like I
mentioned before so at the start of the
mobile web this was a really big part of
their way of accessing information in
this new way that was really growing
after the debut of I mode in 1999 by may
two thousand one more than 40 million
Japanese were accessing their internet
via their mobile phones on a daily basis
this is opposed to about 4 million North
Americans at the same time in 2001 so
there's a huge difference there and
again this is about the time that I went
to Japan so I can really say from my own
personal experience that this difference
was massive and it was a bit shocking in
hindsight and this number nearly doubled
slightly less than two years later
according to the Japanese Ministry of
telecommunications so things weren't
really slowing down at all people are
really grabbing on to this in all of
this high level use led to new
innovation
some of which had a lasting impact so
these are some of the things that people
were using their mobile web for that
have had a lasting impact on how we use
our mobile phones today and a lot of
these came out of the ways that people
were either looking to use their phones
wanted to use their phones we're
naturally adapting their behavior to use
their phones without realizing it um
some of these are the male magazine
which is really like a newsletter but it
was sent directly to your phone usually
as a multimedia male um it's kind of a
proto blog a lot of people were using
these as a sort of blogging newsletter
but some companies found a marketing
value in this and they would send it to
their customers as a way to advertise
their deals or to advertise upcoming
marketing campaigns this also is sort of
in the realm of micro blogging as well
there was a system that was kind of
similar to twitter but really it wasn't
even a formal a system it was a way of
sending SMS messages over networks of
multiple receivers so maybe if you had a
network of 20 or 25 friends you would
just enter in all of their numbers as
the recipients of your message much like
what we have now with what's app or
telegram with a group message and you
could actually include everybody into
these things and in a really sort of
primitive way this was a lot like
Twitter we also had RFID mobile system
payments so felica or something called
oh sigh phuket i sigh foo is the word
for wallet so you could actually use
your phone to log payments for things
that would either be added on to your
mobile phone bill at the end of the
month or in later years you were able to
have it as a separate deduction out of
your bank account this also helps to
increase people's attention and
priorities towards mobile web security
and eventually this also came to
influence smartphone development for web
security as well streaming video and
television now we watch you
tube or we listen to music or we have
some type of receiver on our phone where
we can watch movies or what have you we
don't even think about it twice but back
then and I even had one of these phones
you literally had the screen and the
screen would flip up and you could watch
TV and it had a little antenna and you
could watch your TV just like a normal
TV receiver and that was pretty cool um
so a lot of these sort of bridge
technologies that sort of bridged what
we had an analog all crossed to mobile
they existed they still exist they're
still sort of looked at with a nostalgic
I um and they've brought us into a lot
of the technology we have now where we
can actually watch videos streaming live
on our smartphones my favorite is QR
codes we've all used them and they're a
uniquely Japanese invention and I'm
going to talk about them in depth I'm in
a moment and then finally the mobile
first approach which is really i think
the lasting legacy of the japanese
mobile culture and advent of mobile web
and these last two points are ones that
i'm going to talk about in depth next so
let's take a look at QR codes QR codes
as i said were a uniquely Japanese
invention they were developed by Denzil
wave in 1994 and they were originally
developed as a way to tag automobiles
during the production process so as they
went through the factory they could
track which stage of production each
individual automobile was at and the
reason why there was such a
revolutionary invention was that these
QR codes were so able to have very dense
amounts of data and metadata attached to
them um once they caught up and the in
the industry was able to use them as a
regular benchmark people started
realizing that they could also use it to
get information across using what we're
now new camera phones so this is also
the late 90s early 2000s so people could
use their camera phones to take pictures
of the QR codes
and then you would get something called
mobile tagging so this is where you
would actually take a photo of a QR code
off of an actual physical object like a
newspaper or an advertisement a
billboard and take the picture and it
would bring you away from the physical
world on to the digital world it's also
called hard linking and this is a really
important thing we may sort of take it
for granted now because it's an action
we do all the time people give us
business cards with QR codes we see QR
codes at the bottom of advertisements on
flyers for parties we see them
everywhere we're so used to whipping out
our phones snapping a quick picture we
don't think twice about it but back then
this was really one of these actions
that brought us out of the physical
world and into the digital world in a
very real way and I think that the
semiotic sand the iconography the
feeling the archetypes of these kinds of
actions are really really telling about
how we've come to relate to the digital
world so this idea of mobile tagging and
hard linking and bridging away from the
physical world into the digital world
was a big part of us being able to
integrate mobile web into our everyday
lives we use them for everything from
vcards to mobile marketing um after
their practical industrial purposes were
clearly shown people started to realize
that you could use it to get digital
business cards to market directly to
different demographics because let's
face it everybody was looking at their
phones all the time to get that
information on the web so this began the
very real integration of mobile web into
not only Japanese society of the time
but also into our society as a whole um
the next lasting legacy is the mobile
first approach this may seem kind of
like a no-brainer because we are very
mobile first minded these days but then
again we have to really think about
where it came from mobile access
outnumbered pc access by a great amount
so mobile sites were given priority by
projects management teams by companies
who were looking to create their digital
presence so often what would happen
is that you would get this really
accessible mobile site okay it loves
text and blue linking and lots of tiny
image mapping but at the time it was
extremely accessible but when you went
to their PC site as I called it it was
really kind of a dead zombie site it
really didn't give you much information
maybe as a consumer there wasn't much
there you could use maybe it was just
their address and some information about
what the company does but it wasn't
anything that consumers could use to
actually access their product but when
you looked at the digital counterpart on
mobile there was everything you needed
there to find out where to buy it where
you could use it how you could use it
where you could find support any kinds
of campaigns or deals that might be
coming up for that product so there was
a huge gap between this very utilitarian
mobile site and this very sort of dead
almost perfunctory corporate site on PCs
so you could see definitely that the
priorities lay on the mobile side of
things again the bias towards text and
blue linking just simply made it easy
for people to see on their mobile phones
image mapping was also something that
made it easier for people to see but it
also turned out that these priorities
also sort of started to leak into the pc
design as well so you saw lots of
websites that you were accessing with
your pc we're actually looking almost
like two mobile sites if they were ones
that had information on them at all
there is also the use of the individual
identification number this is another
mobile first not so much in innovation
but the way that they used it in order
to be able to help increase increasing
tracking so for example using the iin as
a proto cookie from a mobile web access
because remember there was no like
client-side scripting at that point with
those types of phones so they were using
the iin as a way to actually make sort
of a marker or tag for which individual
user was using which kinds of services
or visiting which kind of sites so QR
codes mobile first approach I think are
two of the largest
Agassi's that are left from that era at
the moment and because of that a lot of
the industry was able to gain a lot of
power so let's look at power and the I
mode business model is the foundation of
which mobile and digital apps marketing
is based on as we know it today it's so
much so that Steve Jobs is said to have
based the Apple App Store on the
business model of I mode I find that
pretty interesting um there's a lot of
emphasis on development there's a lot of
emphasis on developing new ways to
deliver content to people of course and
this set the stage for App Center
technologies that we have now that are
mostly found for smartphones so what
does this mean well this means that the
mobile web perforated faster than the
home web this means that mobile first
was first in Japan and it also set the
pace and direction for tech and business
models later on um so now it's later
what's going on now where does it where
is it left to go I think it's a kind of
interesting time for mobile web in Japan
at the moment because there's almost two
different worlds that coexist there's
this really wonderfully nostalgic
culture for gotta k and all of these
feature phones that are still being
produced and still being designed some
just for designs sake some for novelty
snake some for nostalgia sake but a lot
of them are also still very much serving
a real function for example phones made
for the elderly or phones made for small
children where parents don't want their
children to have too much access to the
web for example which is a problem with
smartphones um so I think that these
will continue to exist and I think
they'll continue to serve a purpose it
in fact for example a lot of times
during disasters like earthquakes these
feature phones can sometimes be a
lifesaver so a lot of people that I know
still have both their smartphone and
their feature phone it's a backup and I
don't think that's a bad idea at all um
and of course people in Japan are using
smartphones for all the things we're
using them now social networking chat
games shopping surfing but now it's
mostly on
our phones I say mostly because people
are still using these got okay but then
again I don't think those are going to
go away and i think that the advent of
smartphones is tipped power but not a
whole lot um i think that what's going
to happen is that there's going to be a
bit of a flattening of the whole culture
smartphones are more or less similar I
mean we have different features we have
different models what have you but
they're all based on very app centric
technology whereas feature phones aren't
they're very individual there each model
is extremely different from the last
each provider has a different array of
ranges of handsets available so I think
there's a diversity that's available
with these feature phones doesn't really
play out in the same way in the
smartphone field um so I think that
there's probably gonna be a muting of
the market but I also think that there's
still potential for a lot of interesting
maybe more artistic Oh interesting or
interesting or artistic ways to design
these feature phones um one thing I want
to point out is the statistic I want to
come back to from before that the
fastest-growing subset of mobile web
users is age 5 or younger this is also a
function of smartphones a lot of parents
are using them as educational tools for
their children they're very image based
children are able to touch the screens
and be tactile with them which is very
important so I'm it maybe it's a bit of
a skewed statistic because of the way
that people use their smartphones and I
think that in that sense that's where
that generation is going to miss out on
some of the advantages of having these
feature phones um in that sense
smartphones were kind of slow to
penetrate in Japan and this is an
interesting case I wanted to focus on a
little bit with iphone vs android the
fun fact about this is that iphone was a
bit slow to catch on in japan because
there wasn't really much of a carrier
choice it wasn't available in japan
until mid-2008 and Softbank
which was Vodafone which was Jay phone
had a three-year monopoly on iPhone and
iPad retail and contracts before number
portability became an option in late two
thousand eleven people were really
reluctant to change their carriers
because if they changed their carriers
they lost their phone number so people
were very loyal to their carriers and I
think this also has another factor in
the sense of all of these feature phones
and how people would stick with the same
carrier and choose their future phones
but in fact since number portability is
come about Japan is the only market
where Android has actually had a gain of
nearly eight percentage points in the
last two years and this is from a survey
done by the Kantar Worldpanel and I
think that's quite interesting as well
because um this shows again a bit of a
tipping into a diversity of app related
technologies for smartphones that wasn't
necessarily there before so it could be
interesting to see where that goes um so
what are the takeaways about this well
early mobile web adoption set the
priorities for how mobile web was
developed our mobile first approach and
how a mobile and non mobile web
interacted with each other um I drove
the use of innovations like blogs RFID
payment systems lay the groundwork for
streaming video and TV and QR codes and
more and smartphone proliferation is
muted the market so maybe
compartmentalization is going to give us
a bit of imagine a but improving the
existing issues in web design as it
affects desktop oriented sites as
something that's also gotten better
there's been more emphasis on
integration of the two approaches a
smartphone-based client-side scripting
use happens so we'll see that maybe that
gap between the more feature phone style
websites which is still very much a part
of Japanese front end today and
smartphone style apt driven very flat
design sites will start to close a
little bit more and I also hope this
means that will slowly see an end to
these zombie sites these sites where
it's just sort of a perfunctory
corporate site for a particular company
and that will actually move towards more
of the Western
style diversity of different web sites
and many sites that are available to
educate the consumer about products or
services and so yeah I think that's
where the future's going to take us um
oh I want to say thank you to everybody
who came today and there's a list of
people here i want to thank um yeah and
i hope that you can see the legacy of
japanese web mobile um used when you
look at your smartphone when you use
your apps and that maybe hopefully
someday you'll work on a project that
helps to bridge this gap a little bit
more thank you
you